be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so continuing our x-men
encyclopedia what I want to do here is
have a conversation about gambit right
in like three years ago we made a video
called who is gambit but it wasn't
really one of our in-depth character
explanation videos it was more of like a
brief run over kind of thing so we're
gonna be a lot more in depth in this one
but gambit first appeared and there's
actually a couple of appearances of the
character of gambit right there's
there's uncanny x-men annual number
fourteen uh in 1990 then there's
actually uncanny x-men issue number 266
that takes place in the same year it
says literally one after the other right
so July is when the annual came out in
August is when issued to 66 came out and
and of course gambit was created by
Chris Claremont but the reality is that
gambits creation by Chris Claremont
wasn't really done for any one reason in
particular right aside from the fact
that Claremont just wanted to introduce
new characters that's one of things we
talked about in previous videos you know
when Chris Claremont took over the X
minute with issue number 94 or I guess
uncanny x-men issue number 94 1975 that
the original x-men roster was
essentially out the door right they were
being shuffled out that ah that angel
and I guess really Warren Worthington
and Iceman had had been taken off the
team by Marvel and put on to the
champions of Los Angeles and in
champions number one in 1975 that an
Avengers issue number 141 beasts had
left the x-men team and joined the
Avengers themselves the original members
were on their way out right you know
Jean Grey basically died at the end of
the Phoenix saga Cyclops left because of
that and so it was really to kind of
like this systematic method of removing
the old x-men and even going so far with
with x-men issue number 200 to take
Xavier off as leader of the team to send
him out into space and to have magneto
take over the team so it was like a
wholesale relaunch that took multiple
years to you know to get to that point
but like a wholesale relaunch of the
x-men roster and it was exceedingly
popular you know people people loved a
lot of the stuff that was going on there
but but really the introduction of gamma
didn't sort of any other purpose than
the fact that Claremont just wanted to
make a guy and throw him in there um the
issue with this and not really even an
issue but but the idea behind this is
that with with gambit showing up in
issue number 266 he appeared as part of
an existing story that centered around
storm and the reason why was because
storm had basically been held as a
captive of Manny in the orphan maker and
many an end the orphan maker they were
like a weird duo right they were kind of
like this weird thing where basically
they would take individuals and then
like be aged them you know and then like
keep them as kids you almost kind of
like trophies storm have been taken and
then of course she managed to make her
escape but at the same
time she was also fleeing the Shadow
King just because of the fact that storm
in the shadow King had a very long
history with each other right you know
storm actually worked for the shadow
king albeit when he was operating under
the guise of Amahl Farouk and when she
had managed to make her escape when when
shadow king was defeated and then
ultimately she ended up leaving Egypt
and then traveling to the Serengeti and
then taking over as kind of like their
goddess more or less you know because
there were powers over over weather
manipulation the shadow king had always
been trying to reacquire her right so
this is one of the closest that he'd
gotten to and and in truth her running
into gambit was just happenstance my
gambit just happened to be there on a
mission to steal something that was
already there and so because of the fact
that gamut basically helps storm to
escape by this point Xavier had been
returned to the x-men and he was taking
back over leadership on the team and
storm essentially vouch for gambit to
join the x-men itself and of course he
was off to become part of the team after
that the funny thing about this is that
at the time gambit had no real origin we
didn't know anything about him and it
wasn't like he appeared in a story like
we got his whole origin as he was
talking to storm around some kind of
campfire or something like that he was
just there and on the team and the
reality was that at the time that was
that was not really part and parcel to
to Marvel but it was a system that could
work depending on how it was done but it
would it came to the character of gambit
in terms of what his origin was a lot of
this was actually fleshed out in the
third volume of his a miniseries and the
way this played out was that in and
again at volume three issue number one
which is really where you get this you
get you get some of it an x-men vol 2
issue number 8 but in gambit vol 3
issue number one what you end up
learning is that much like the villain
apocalypse actually gambit was abandoned
by his original of birth parents due to
the fact that he had glowing red eyes
but he was ultimately rescued and taken
in by the Thieves Guild now within the
state of New Orleans and even really the
the state's not the only place read the
the thieves and the Assassin's Guild ah
they spread across the world right there
literally worldwide but each one is his
own individual sell its own individual
organizations with his own individual
rules and different things like that but
within the state of Louisiana in the
city of New Orleans the Thieves Guild
and the Assassin's Guild basically paid
tithe to a woman named Kandra and she
was an external who was really one of
the only people who had possession of
the elixir of life now some of you guys
who were familiar with the elixir of
life may also know it as the Infinity
formula which is the formula that was
consumed by the the old-school white guy
Nick Fury
and it's Howling Commandos which gave
Nick Fury his longevity right but but
the idea behind this was that those
individuals who paid the tithe every 7
years and who earned the approval of of
Kandra would be given what's called the
elixir of life which would basically
prolong their existence the issue with
this is that the assassins and the
thieves were always at war with each
other and so gambit was essentially
brought up in that environment now from
there that's when you get an x-men vol 2
issue number 8 and you basically get
this explanation that gambit as he was
growing up ultimately met and fell in
love with a girl named belladonna but
during that time his powers were also
developing albeit he didn't really know
how to use them and so in order to
essentially create a kind of truce
between the assassins and the thieves
that gambit as a member of the
Assassin's Guild and really one of its
top guys who had worked as it worked his
way up the ranks would marry belladonna
of the of the Assassin's Guild the
problem with this was that belladonna's
brother I think it was Julian ultimately
didn't agree with it and so as a result
of that he challenged gambit to a duel
and during the fight gambit basically
impaled Julian and then his powers
activated and so he basically you know
kinetically charged the sword which
exploded killed Julian and then it was
believed that gambit had commited a ruse
right because it was dishonorable to
kill him in that way to use powers order
to essentially cheap and so as a result
of that gambit was exiled from from the
Thieves Guild and from New Orleans
itself and then basically kind of went
forward into the world now that's when
you start to get into the the element
and really in a lot of ways the
involvement of mr. sinister now the
involvement of mr. sinister in the
origin of gambit actually comes in two
locations the first one is part of it on
or at least not really an ongoing but
part of a story called the trial of
gambit and the second one is actually
x-men origins gambit now the the x-men
origins line of comics were a whole
bunch of one-shots who were released not
too long ago really by Marvel comics as
a way to kind of consolidate all the
information regarding the origin of a
character down into a single comic book
the downside to that is that when you're
talking about the release of origins for
characters that are done over a series
of particular stories there's a lot of
information there and so when you're
talking about reducing that down to a
one-shot comic a lot of it gets lost in
the shuffle but the overall idea behind
this was that gambit had essentially
travelled the world for some time as a
master thief just kind of making his way
honing his skills so on and so forth
carrying out different jobs for
different individuals but the inability
to control his powers was for the most
part the bane of his existence and so
ultimately he ended up approaching mr.
sinister and
and this part were really gonna kind of
take out of out of uncanny x-men number
350 but he ended up approaching mr.
sinister for the purpose of figuring out
if this guy who was you know considered
to be a mutant geneticist could help him
control his abilities and the result was
that sinister could he actually end up
performing a partial lobotomy on gambit
and basically reduced his powers but but
kept them in a manageable level the
problem with this was that gambit
effectively became in the debt of mr.
sinister and so what sinister told him
is that at some point in time I will
call on you for a favor right so very
Godfather like in that regard but I'll
call on you for a favor and you will
have to fulfill this it's really just
like an honor bound thing Plus like I
could kill you you know and that kind of
a thing so because of that this really
came to a head during a story called the
mutant massacre and this really sort of
book ended and and tied into the events
of the trial of gambit so kind of you
know pardon me here because we're sort
of jumping forward a little bit kind of
jumping around here a bit but we'll
actually get into the publication side
of things here in a second but the idea
behind this was that sinister as a
mutant geneticist had come to believe
that these various mutants who existed
in the sewers of New York due to the
fact that their mutant manifestations
created physical changes in their bodies
that would make them outcasts right so
they weren't like Jean Grey or Cyclops
or they could walk around and pretend to
look like normal humans their physical
appearance would change in a lot of
different ways right so they were very
similar to like Hank McCoy two beasts of
the x-men as well as a result of that
sinister had believed it like the
Morlocks were a result of his own
genetic experimentations and so what he
did is he assembled a group called the
Marauders some of which you guys know
like Sabretooth things like that and
then he had tasked a gambit because of
his abilities as a thief being able to
sneak into places things like that he
tasked gambit with leading the Marauders
into the sewers of New York and killing
the Morlocks the issue is a gambit
didn't really know what was going on and
he wasn't told by sinister due to the
fact the game it probably would have
turned it down and then tried to put up
a fight and ultimately leave or at the
very least agree to do it and then kill
them or otters along the way and so as a
result of that gambit didn't know what
was gonna happen until he got there and
until the Marauders started killing all
the different Morlocks now gambit tried
to put up a fight but was ultimately
entered by Sabretooth who was able to
save a girl but ultimately you know it
was it was gambit realizing that he have
led these these Marauders into the
sewers and massacred you know all these
different Morlocks now but the mutant
Massacre was also an exceedingly
important storyline and the x-men to
kind of sidetrack here for a second it
was an exceedingly important storyline
in the x-men history because of the fact
that
the first major crossover of all the
x-men titles right of like New Mutants
and an x-men and x-factor it was a huge
story that was launched at the time and
so it even had a couple tie-ins with
Thor but it was it was massive and in
scale you know we've never really seen
anything like that with regards to the
x-men universe crossing over in that way
and so as a result of that and that
really you know Left gambit kind of
taking off and going off to do his own
thing which bookends into his appearance
in uncanny x-men number 266 and his
essential first appearance you know when
he when he first encountered storm and
so going in and and joining the x-men
team the funny thing about this was that
with gambit showing up when he did there
was about a two-year window when Gannett
was sort of there and if you were
reading x-men comics it was cool like he
was a pretty interesting character he
almost immediately fell in love with
rogue and wrote fell in love with him
the issue was they couldn't touch
because of ropes powers so that created
a sort of romantic dynamic but in
reality gambit didn't really take off in
counter book form and till the release
of x-men the animated series and the
reason why was because for a lot of
people at the time who weren't really
getting into comic books but who knew
who the x-men were an animated series
based off that team based off something
on Marvel and with it being produced as
well as it was at least for the first
four seasons anyway resonated people
loved it people will people adore to in
effect is actually how I got into comic
books and because gambit was one of the
main stars there because of how he was
depicted the fact that you know he was
kind of in a relationship with rogue and
he had this sort of devil-may-care
attitude and in the sense that he was
reckless and and so on and so forth
people loved him and so what I did is it
actually skyrocketed the popularity of
of gambit and Marvel Comics as to what
this did is in 1993 it actually led to
the first mini-series that centered on
gambit with him travelling back to New
Orleans in order to deal with a
confrontation between the the assassins
and the thieves but here's the reason
why I say gammas appearance also came at
the worst hunt is because in 1992 Chris
Claremont left he was just gone out of
atom Marvel but he basically bailed on
Marvel because he had creative
differences with Jim Lee who was the
artist at the time as well as Marvel
editorial and then within the within a
year of that in 93 Jim Lee left Marvel
to create Image Comics alongside Todd
McFarlane and Eric Larsen and Marc
Silvestri and so on and so forth and so
what this meant was that the DEA almost
the entire x-men line was just kind of
thrown into the air right it wasn't a
great big huge shuffle and things were
sort of in an in a state of panic right
because you know with Chris Claremont
being like there on a Tuesday
gone on a Wednesday a lot of the plot
threads were just totally left open and
Gimli tried to wrap a lot of them up as
best he could but then ultimately ended
up leaving as well and so a lot of these
threads were just kind of out there they
were scattered and I was in a state of
panic and and you know when you take
that and you combine it with the fact
that within a year and a half of that
there would be the college bus of the
1990s and Marvel phase II potential
bankruptcy it was panic mode right I
mean you've got Scott Liddell right in
the x-men comics and trying to make
things work as best he could but at the
end of the day a lot of stuff was
suffering all over the place when you
compound that with the fact that x-men
the animated series had essentially gone
off the air and and when people went to
go look at Marvel Comics and they saw
the x-men landscape in such a state of
disarray people were just kind of like
unscrew that and so they basically just
didn't read and so because of that going
into the really the the third volume
which is to say like with with gambit
you had two miniseries and then you had
three ongoing series the first of which
was the longest one I'm if you if you
look at it in terms of like the
chronological history of gambits ongoing
series technically it's volume 1 as the
first mini-series volume 2 is the second
and then volume 3 is the first ongoing
series but it's considered you know the
third volume of gambits on the
individual run which is par for the
course but going into his ongoing series
in 1999 there were a few things going on
here you know things like for example he
ended up travelling back to back to New
Orleans
he ended up unifying the fees and the
Assassin's Guild there were some hot
threats with belladonna that were
wrapped up wrapped up different things
like that but one of the only really big
things that came out of that is he ended
up basically working for this mysterious
guy by the name of New Sun and he didn't
really know exactly who New Sun was it
was just the guy who was basically
working for or that he was working for
and and so on and so forth especially
because of the fact that he was
basically just hiding in the Savage Land
a lot of that went into a story arc that
evolved him more or less being like
possessed by a wraith named Mary which
we're not gonna go into because it's
stupid is it's it really really really
is just stupid but ultimately working
for this guy named New Sun the third
volume basically bookended into the the
launch of extreme x-men in 2001 and
basically included with gambit coming to
the realization that New Sun was an
alternate reality version of himself and
that in that alternate reality his
powers flared out of control and
incinerated everybody on Earth and so
what New Sun had been doing was
traveling from one reality to the next
and and basically killing every version
of himself in order to ensure that would
never truly happen this basically led to
gambit travelling to
passed and having his powers fully
restored by sinister and then traveling
back to the present day and then
ultimately fighting New Sun and
defeating him following that his powers
are basically reduced is his powers
would return back to her normal state
but that went into the extreme x-men run
by Chris Claremont now the extreme x-men
run was Chris Claremont returned to
Marvel Comics and to work on work on the
x-men titles and depending on who you
talked to there are some people who
loved extreme x-men I personally didn't
but there were some people who loved
extreme x-men there are some people who
just hated extreme agitation it's it
really did split the x-men community in
a lot of different ways it was the first
real attempt to try to reinvigorate
interest it was Marvel - it was really
Quezada coming on as editor-in-chief and
saying well if we're basically gonna
relaunch Marvel and Chris Claremont was
the guy who made the x-men great done
let's bring him back and let's see where
it goes and so what you ended up getting
here were stories that that weren't
necessarily lackluster but stories that
were relatively interesting the first
volume for example dealt with with
tracking down destinies Diaries these 13
Diaries they would basically specify
like the future of events to come
different things like that
gambit kind of became a more involved
character once you got to the second
volume it didn't really stick and
resonate with people in a lot of
different ways it was an ongoing series
that really kind of ran as a companion
to new x-men at the time but for the
most part he was just kind of a guy who
was there he was a background character
and in a lot of ways gambit was just
sort of free-floating after the events
of really like the late 1990s going into
the early 2000s and so what this did is
this basically went into the launch of
issue number 171 of x-men vol 2 and the
reason why was because at that point in
time you were dealing with the events
leading up to going into and coming out
of house of M at this point in x-men vol
2 you had Peter Milligan writing the
comic and where there were a lot of
things going on in terms of the overall
x-men landscape for the character of
gambit Peter Milligan's idea was focus
on the classics right like people know
gambit as this guy who's really
mysterious and and you know to a degree
hetero not really even to a degree but
like has this big romantic interest in
rogue so let's stick with that let's go
with the romance of rogue and gambit and
it worked but it actually worked
exceedingly well like people really like
people enjoyed seeing gambit returned to
his classic form as opposed to being
this guy who seemingly shuffled for one
team to the next because Marvel doesn't
know what to do with him and so over the
course of this this particular line of
this Peter story arc that really span
between issues number 160 I would say
running probably all the way up to one
hundred and
72-73 it dealt with gambit and rogue
actually trying to find a way to make
the relationship work but also dealing
with the struggles of their relationship
and the reason for this is that by the
time you got to issue number one 74
mystique had more of an involvement in
the life of road now a lot of that again
kind of goes into the events of in the
aftermath and house of it which we'll
talk about here in a second but what it
did is it led to mystique basically
coming to this belief that gambit was no
good for her daughter basically the
classic mom role you know you're not
good enough for my daughter you got to
prove your worth or something like that
there was one point where mystique
infiltrated the school and then
basically changed shape into somebody
else and and then eventually change
shape in the rogue and tried to seduce
gambit when of course gambit knowing
that it was mystique you know she tried
to seduce him and gambit it was really
kind of left ambiguous you didn't know
if gambit actually did it or not but at
the very least you know it ended up
putting a kind of strain on the
relationship between the two of them and
almost brought the entire theme crashing
to a halt and so what this did is this
basically went into a handful of
different pawn threats one of the big
ones that came out of it was was gambit
viciously joining apocalypse right and
we covered that we covered that story of
gambit becoming a Horsemen of apocalypse
in so far that after the events of house
of M apocalypse woke up due to the fact
that there was this drastic drop in the
mutant population and so you know
apocalypses response was to one go to
humanity go to the governments of the
world and to say because mutants have
lost whatever that you know 98 percent
of their population humanity has to call
the same amount of Norda to keep the
keep it filled even or something along
those lines and then also approach the
x-men basically with his own blood
saying if you consume this you'll become
one of mine and then gambit basically
joined apocalypse in an attempt to
understand what the full complexity of
his plot was and then in turn defeat him
from within but following this and
growing an x-men vol 2 issue number 200
as well as x-men legacy and and the
Messiah Complex what this basically saw
was a handful of things going on with
gambit you know following the fact that
he was a Horsemen of apocalypse he had
basically become death he ended up
travelling to mr. sinister who basically
restored him to his former self but
brought him back in contact with the
Marauders this coincided with the
Messiah Complex and the birth of Hope
Summers the fact that rogue in in the
existing x-men storylines had basically
come into contact with the hecka - which
was like this giant bomb / device that
was owned by or at least operated by the
Shi arc but how's like a billion mines
and and rogue had literally absorbed a
billion people's consciousness all at
one time which put her in a catatonic
state but because of the fact that Hope
Summers
had the ability to - to seemingly you
know he'll pee
and even though her booties weren't
fully fleshed-out Gambit had basically
aided in capturing hope summers bringing
her to mystique and then touching the
baby of baby toorop which basically
cured her of the hecka tomb and account
of altered ROK's powers and so far she
could only channel like one ability at a
time but basically brought wrote doc and
so with that you're really really going
on
going into x-men legacy you ended up
having a gambit really trying to rejoin
the x-men in the traditional sense
meaning he was a consistent member of
the team it worked for a time insofar as
the writing of Mike Carey with regards
to the handling of gambit during x-men
legacy really dealt with the fact that
like the x-men couldn't really accept
him because of the things that he'd done
and while he was officially a part of
the team nobody really seemed to trust
him it was a throwback to the old post
mutant Massacre comics when the x-men
learned or at least believed gambit was
part of the mutant massacre and booted
him out but for the most part for you
know between 2009 running up to around
2018 gambit just kind of free floated he
was just sort of there it seemed like
the the idea of gambit being a mainstay
character you know kind of getting back
to the days of how he was leading up to
and shortly after the the launch of
x-men the anime series that those days
are basically long gone the gambit was
just kind of a free-floating guy who was
there and there wasn't a whole lot of
interest in him
ah this list goes into Avengers vs.
x-men when you basically kind of see the
same thing when you see gambit facing
off against like Captain America for
example you know there were some some
cool moments there you know some some
cool segments that happened here and
there but in terms of you know gambit
you know with gambit vol 5 and as his
you know continued ongoing series in
terms of gamma being like this mainstay
x-men character who continually drew
interest from the larger x-men fan base
it was really there you know it wasn't
really all that interesting and so what
you ended up getting was this this
really really cool scenario the played
out in the 2018 story gambit and rogue
by Kelley Thompson and what this did
this was actually really really amazing
Kelley Thompson's perspective here is it
was really the same perspective as a lot
of writers before her the popularity of
gambit doesn't necessarily lie in him
being a thief and going and stealing
things and and so on and so forth and in
fact that was something that was kind of
wrapped up relatively fast when when he
was part of Wolverines team and
Wolverine was like you can't be a thief
while you're part of the x-men right
like it's not what we do it's not cool
man this really kind of came to a head
with a story when you ended up having
Kitty Pryde who sent gambit and
rogue on this undercover mission to
essentially what was couples therapy but
what it did is it forced the two of them
to basically see the actions of the
other through their own eyes right so
gambits saw everything that he had done
through the eyes of rogues and roguettes
seen everything that she had done
through the eyes of gambit and it was
cool to see it was it was really awesome
because what it did is it really kind of
shined a light on the relationship
between the two characters in a way that
hadn't really been seen before in the
sense that while they had always kind of
been in love and it was always sort of
an on-again off-again situation having
them see the other person through their
own eyes was a way that really kind of
allowed a connection that didn't seem to
exist before and so the result was that
in in probably one of the most
anticipated moments in in malmo comics
for a long time began to propose to
rogue and they were married by a rabbi
at the at the wedding of Katie prior at
least what was supposed to be the
wedding of Kitty Pryde and Colossus the
problem with this is that while it well
it did you know of course see the
story's logical conclusion the last that
we saw of gambit was that he and rogue
had basically been just like teleported
away to the mojo verse which was not
really a good story you know mr. and
mrs. X is okay I guess if that's your
thing but I didn't really get into it
too much I mean it was interesting in so
far as you got to see like all these
crazy lives of like rogue and gambit in
terms of like you know the lives they
could have lived like westerns and and
romance novels and different things like
that but the reality is that since the
relaunch of the x-men going into what
Jonathan Hickman has been doing we
haven't really seen gambit we don't
really know what gambits doing and
that's one of the questions a lot of
people have is like with everything
that's been going on and how some powers
of X with what's going on in Dawn of X
and so on and so forth what are we going
to see gambit the fortunate thing for us
is that with everything going on with
Dawn of X we get to see gambit in
Excalibur weird is gonna be interesting
to see a wholly new launched Excalibur
team I'm curious because it's such a
totally different set up for what we've
seen before but with that being said
guys we're to go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]